it is time for truth news your mini good
news marshmallows floating in that hot
news coco and with me at the desk is
milo marshmallow rusty ross
matthews sounds good
how about those mini marshmallows dude
they're so meaningless
i know all right well speaking of sweets
it's cookie week
and today we're celebrating with some
special creations from funny face bakery
right here in the city they're america's
first pop culture bakery pop culture
bakery yeah i love this pop culture
bakery adele cookies kevin from home
alone cookies the full cast of seinfeld
cookies and they make custom cookies too
check these out okay right here drew
they have made we haven't seen these yet
right in front of you these are cookies
of us
yes but i we haven't seen so three two
oh but look
i have to say
i'm like hi
hold on ready yeah you are a very
attractive cookie i have to say
are you gonna do it let me see
that's adorbs well done um okay first up
we've got huge movie news channing tatum
just posted this to twitter
it's a script for you guessed it a brand
new magic mic you know that amazing yeah
anthology that
he's so
kindly brought to the silver screen and
vegas
and there's like a reality show and now
there's going to be a third installment
variety reports that the third o and
final magic mic movie is coming to hbo
max wait a minute i know why don't do
that farewell thing to me don't why you
gotta stop making that i already got my
tickets for this one you guys are you
kidding
just keep making them i don't care if
you have magic mike aarp okay i'm
showing up
okay are you gonna buy tickets to this
new magic mike i like that i'm steven
soderbergh the amazing director who did
erin brockovich and
oh my graphic traffic and the first
magic mike
and the very first magic mike that he
collaborated with channing tatum he's
just the most talented filmmaker um so
they're going to do it together again
and gosh i hope the whole cast shows up
i'm in yeah i just hope that cookie week
doesn't ruin my chance of getting a part
in this new magic mike movie
next up another woman who does things
her own way paris hilton you know she
just got married congratulations to
paris
um fun fact i actually am making
something very special for her for her
wedding it's in the works it'll be there
soon paris for real yeah
yeah we knew each other when we were
kids
can you tell us what it is you tell us
after you send it or is it like i
figured i should probably wait so that
it's a surprise for her but it's being
engraved right now oh
i'm so happy for her i'm happy for her
too well this is really interesting uh
the cut reports that paris and her new
husband carter rheem they recently went
on their honeymoon to bora bora which
sounds amazing amazing
but they brought the whole hilton family
with them paris's mom and dad kathy and
rick were there on their honeymoon plus
her brothers were there and her
sister-in-law was there and her niece
was there on your honeymoon
you know um
okay i i'm happy for you all that you're
all that close i think that's really
cute
um
i just want to say you know i'm planning
my wedding right now and unless you're
saying i do you don't get to come on the
honeymoon
okay um clap of hands who would take
family or in-laws on honeymoon
thank you thank you
wow that was a resounding clap of hands
who would not take family and love them
[Applause]
do you know what's so funny is i did not
really have family growing up so it's so
novel to me i think i would be totally
open to it you you are that girl you
would totally invite family also they're
making a show there might be
there might be that aspect involved i
don't know though well someone was
filming my honeymoon then yeah bring it
on send the check come on
i just feel like i
i just put the whole wedding on you know
you had the chicken or the fish remember
the dj was there i've done enough for
you now i get the honeymoon well mazel
tov to them being that close
well next we have a beautiful story
about making giving back even easier the
good news network reports that
rockefeller center just got its first
giving machine it's a vending machine
that lets you buy something to help
other citizens
either locally or across the globe and
there's ten
of these across the u.s
states like arizona utah tennessee
hawaii get the full list for around the
country capabilities on our website at
thedrewberrymoreshow.com and this is so
interesting inside the vending machine
you can buy everything from gloves and
socks to chickens and goats for people
which is very important for food
bartering you name it
polio vaccines for kids passover meals
it's beautifully curated elegantly um
designed and is just something you know
for everyone all around the planet and
i'm very happy to see something like
this taking place it's beautiful
and they raised
like millions and millions of dollars
worth of things for people you know my
dad would tell a story when he was
growing up he was really poor growing up
and they didn't have christmas and on
christmas eve the church showed up with
some presents and every christmas he
would talk about what that meant and
anybody who's ever been in need i didn't
grow up wealthy either we know
what this means when you can't provide
for yourself the fact that we can come
together as humanity when we need it
most this is brilliant thank you for
making this also
sometimes
you don't exactly know where to go or
what to do and these machines have
generated 6.2 million dollars
in revenue and gifts
for people
and they help groups like unicef the
actors fund the unhcr
the u.n refugee agency
um i'm just
you know i've always wanted
philanthropy to be
easier and more accessible
for people i i'm i'm i'm gonna go to
rockefeller center and go with the girls
and and the fact that this is
around the country too and not just in
coastal cities but like all over the
place
more and more and more more more more
well done you all
[Music]